Bitte schön.
Ja. Schönen guten Tag. Ich heiße Mustafa Çelik und ich bin hier auf der Station als Assistenzartätich und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Anamnesegespräch durchführen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Okay. Kurz zum Ablauf. Ich werde Ihnen zuerst ein paar gemeine Fragen stellen und danach werden wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden sprechen.
Das ist okay.
Okay, bitte geben Sie mir Bescheid oder fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen.
Mhm, gut.
Okay, los geht's. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Andreas Schollte.
Andreas Schollten.
Können Sie bitte Ihre Vornamen und Nachnamen bestabieren?
Der Vornamen ist A-N-G-M-E-A-S.
E-W-M-E-A-S.
Okay.
Andreas und dann Schollten S-C-H-O-L-T-E-N.
Ja, okay, wunderbar. Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Schollten?
Ich bin 33 Jahre.
Okay, und wann sind Sie hier noch geboren?
Am 18.05.1990.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,86 m.
1,86 m.
Okay. Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
98 kg.
Fast 100 kg.
98 klingt besser.
Ja, okay.
Ich habe immer Probleme mit deutschen Nummern, deswegen.
Ja, okay. Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich habe solche ganz extremen Kopfschmerzen auf der linken Seite.
Das strahlt bis in die Schulter rein, bis in den Arm.
Ich habe das Gefühl, das geht am Hinterkopf hoch.
Mir ist wirklich, ich fühle mich jetzt so schlecht,
dass mir schlecht ist und ich kann nicht mehr schlafen.
Wegen Schmerzen?
Wegen der Schmerzen? Ja.
Okay. Seit wann haben Sie diese Kopfschmerzen?
Ja, das hat vor vier Tagen angefangen.
Dann habe ich gedacht, na ja gut, das geht dann wieder weg.
Aber das wird immer schlimmer.
Und inzwischen habe ich das Gefühl, ich kann mich überhaupt nicht mehr bewegen.
Ich war jetzt heute auch dann nicht bei der Arbeit,
weil ich das Gefühl habe, ich kann überhaupt gar nicht an meinem Arbeitsplatz sitzen.
Und wenn ich aufstehen muss oder wenn ich mich zu einer anderen Seite drehen muss,
ist das alles extrem Schmerzhaft.
Okay, verstehe. Das kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen.
Können Sie mir beschreiben, sind die Schmerzen eher dumm?
Das brennt richtig im Kopf und so ein ziehenes Gefühl.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft da oder treten sie hinten wieder auf?
Ja, die hören nicht auf.
Wenn ich ganz still liege, dann dröhnt nur der Kopf.
Aber wenn ich versuche, aufzustehen oder so, dann merke ich das extrem,
dass es eben so ausstrahlt.
Ja, wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf eines Kalapons 1 mit 10?
Hier 1 entspricht sehr leichten Schmerzen und den sehr starken Schmerzen.
Ja, also ich würde schon über der Hälfte sagen.
Ich würde bei 6 sagen.
Schmerzen, okay.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser für die Schmerzen?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Das hat ja langsam angefangen.
Ich weiß nicht, was es ist.
Ich habe überlegt, ich schieße zu schicken ganzen.
Bewegung essen kann ein guter Auslöser sein?
Beim Essen habe ich nichts bemerkt.
Ich habe nicht etwas Besonderes gegessen.
Ich kann mich jetzt gar nicht belasten.
Ich kann mich kaum rühren.
Ich arbeite natürlich viel am Computer.
Vielleicht habe ich da eine schlechte Haltung.
Ich habe jetzt auch das Gefühl, ich kann nicht mal vernünftig auf ein Bildschirm was sehen.
Das kann sein, ja.
Gibt es etwas oder haben Sie bemerkt, dass die Schmerzen verschlechtert oder verbessert?
Ich habe mir mal so ein Wärmekissen auf den linken nacken Schulter gelegt.
Da hatte ich das Gefühl, dass es ein bisschen besser wird.
Das Schwierigste ist im Bett liegen und die Lage, die Position zu verändern.
Wenn man dann aufstehen will und nach dem Wecker gucken,
hat man das Gefühl, man weiß gar nicht, wo man anfangen soll.
Haben Sie irgendeine Medikamente dagegen eingenommen?
Ich habe versucht, ein paar Tage mit Ibuprofen, aber das hat gar nichts verändert.
Ibuprofen funktioniert nicht.
Sie haben gesagt, im Laufe der Zeit haben sich die Schmerzen verschlechtert.
Sie haben seit vier Tagen nicht verschlechtert.
Hatten Sie einen Unfall oder eine Verletzung?
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Ich muss mir Notizen machen, deswegen habe ich seit einigen Tagen nicht verletzt.
Hatten Sie schon einmal solche Beschwerden?
Ich habe schon mal Kopfschmerzen gehabt, aber dass das so tagelang ist und so heftig ist,
kann ich mich nicht erinnern.
Okay, solche nicht erinnern können.
Sind Sie schon mal bei dem Arzt gewiesen?
Mit diesen Schmerzen bin ich noch nicht beim Arzt gewiesen.
Haben Sie Schütterlfrost oder Nachtschweiß oder kalten Schwerfen?
Nein, ich spritze nicht.
Ich fühle mich auch nicht fieberisch.
Müssen Sie sich übergeben oder haben Sie Übelkeit?
Schlecht ist mir und ich habe das Gefühl, ich kann jetzt zurzeit ganz schlecht nur essen.
Ich habe überhaupt gar keinen Appetit.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Maseradassin?
Eigentlich nicht.
Leiden Sie unter Durchfall oder Verstopfung?
Nein, mein Verdauern ist eigentlich ganz normal.
Okay, das ist gut.
Sie haben keinen Appetit.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder durchgenommen?
Nein, abnehmen wir ja.
Ich habe mein Gewichtes immer gleich.
Haben Sie Taubheitsgefühl oder Lehmung in irgendwelchen Klockerregionen?
Das ist wichtig für Kopfschmerzen, deswegen habe ich gefragt.
Was mir aufgefallen ist, ist meine linke Hand, dass sie so ein bisschen zittert.
Aber eine Lehmungbericht ist, habe ich nicht.
Und Kribbel tut es da auch nicht.
Aber ich kann die so ein bisschen schlechter kontrollieren.
War Ihnen schwindelig oder schwarz von den Augen?
Nein, schwarz vor Augen war mir nicht.
Und schwindelig war mir auch nicht.
Gut, dann gut.
Haben Sie Ihr Bewusstsein verloren?
Nein, nein, nein.
Okay, das ja.
Leiden Sie an irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen?
Ich meine Zücherkrankheit oder Bluthochdruck?
Nein, das einzige was ich habe, ich habe ein bisschen viel Stress bei der Arbeit.
Ich habe seit sechs Jahren schon einen, na ne, so lange ist das noch nicht.
Ja, so vier, fünf Jahren habe ich einen Tinnitus, hat man festgestellt.
Seit fünf Jahren Tinnitus?
Okay, würden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, als Kind habe ich mal einen Unterarm hoch gehabt.
Und da hatte ich einen Fahrradunfall und das ist operativ versorgt worden.
Das ist aber eigentlich gut verheilt.
Wie alt war Sie damals?
Oh, da bin ich gerade zur Schule gewesen.
Also ich war so sieben oder acht, weiß ich nicht genau.
Okay, sind Sie vollständig ging?
Gegen Corona bin ich geimpft, ja, ja.
Okay, ja.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente ein?
Nein, also wie gesagt, habe ich ja ein Iwo Profil mal probiert, aber das hat nicht geholfen.
Sonst regelmäßig nehme ich überhaupt nicht ein.
Okay, das ist gut.
Haben Sie Allergie?
Ja, ich habe eine Pollenallergie.
Wie äußert sich?
Ja, die äußert sich eben mit Schnupfen und laufender Nase und trennenden Augen und so.
Und wenn das ganz schlimm ist, dann muss ich halt mal so Nasenspray benutzen oder so.
Okay.
Aber sonst nehme ich keine Medikamente an.
Okay, haben Sie Unverträglichkeiten?
Ja, diese Pollenallergie habe ich halt.
Ja.
Okay, okay, ja.
Herr Scholten, raufen Sie?
Ja, also Rauchen kann man das eigentlich nicht nennen.
Ich bin eigentlich nur so ein Mitläuferraucher.
Ich rauche so 50er Retten am Tag.
Also so mit den Kollegen zusammen in der Arbeitspause oder auch wenn man abends mal eingeladen ist,
wenn alle rausgehen auf dem Balkon, dann brauche ich halt eine mit,
aber ich brauche jetzt nicht wirklich viel.
Okay, das bedeutet, Sie kaufen keine Zigaret-Paket, ja?
Sie rauchen mit Freunden.
Ja, doch, manchmal rauchen schon auch welche.
Okay, seit wann rauchen Sie?
Seit ich 21 bin, also 12 Jahre.
Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, am Wochenende mal, wenn es irgendwas zu feiern gibt oder ja, wenn man sich einen gemütlichen Abend macht,
dann trinke ich schon mal ein Bier oder auch zwei oder drei Bier.
Und ja, je nachdem, wenn man eingeladen ist, auch mal ein Glas Wein oder so.
Ja, ja können wir sagen zwei oder drei Bier pro Woche oder?
Ja, wahrscheinlich trifft das so ungefähr zu ja.
Okay, diese Frage ist eine Routine-Prager, bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit dem Drogen?
Mit Drogen habe ich keine Erfahrung, nein.
Okay, lieben Ihre Eltern noch?
Meine Eltern leben noch, ja, ja.
Sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Ja, also mein Vater hat ein bisschen Herzprobleme.
Der hat vor zwei Jahren so ein Stent in den Herzgefäßen bekommen,
aber seitdem geht es ihm eigentlich wieder ganz gut.
Und meine Mutter, die ist eigentlich auch ganz fit, die hat vor vier Jahren
ein neues Kniegelenk bekommen, aber sonstige Krankheiten hat sie eigentlich nicht.
Künstliche Kniegelenke, ja, okay.
Künstliches Kniegelenk, ja.
Das ist gut. Wie alt ist Ihr Vater?
Mein Vater ist, muss ich rechnen, er ist 70 und meine Mutter ist 68.
70 Vater, 68.
Okay.
Junger Menschen, ja, kann man sagen, okay.
Ja, ja.
Gab es Fälle von Krebs in der Familie?
So viel, ich weiß nicht, nein.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Eine Geschwester habe ich ja.
Ja, und sind Sie gesund?
Sie ist gesund, ja.
Okay, das ist auch gut.
Eine Krankheit, ja.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben viel Stress bei der Arbeit.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ich arbeite beim Einwohneramt der Stadt.
Einwohneramt.
Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Wir haben natürlich sehr viel Publikumsverkehr und ja, man kämpft mit der Technik und dann immer wieder neue, neue Verordnungen und neue Gesetze.
Und dann muss man ständig umstellen. Also wir haben schon viel zu tun.
Ja, das kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen. Ja.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin ledig.
Ledig? Okay. Wollen Sie allein oder?
Ich lebe in meiner Freundin zusammen.
Okay.
Okay, das ist gut.
Haben Sie Haustiere?
Nein, haben wir nicht.
Okay. Ja, das war es.
Ich möchte eine kurze Zusammenfassung machen, um möglicher Fehler zu vermeiden.
Herr Scholtern.
Sie sind Andreas Scholtern und Sie sind 33 Jahre alt.
Sie sind 1,86 m groß und 98 kg schwer.
Kilogramm schwer.
Sie haben extrem Kopfschmerzen seit 4 Tagen.
Ja.
Und diese Schmerzen strahlen in linke Arme aus.
In den linken Arm, ja.
Und hinter Kopf fühlen Sie sich sehr heftige Schmerzen.
Mhm.
Ja.
Sie haben beschreibt diese Schmerzen als bedenrend.
Und siehend, ein bisschen siehend.
Okay.
Ja.
Es gibt keine Auslöser.
Nur Wärmekisten ein bisschen funktioniert gegen Schmerzen.
Das hat ein bisschen, das hat ein bisschen Linderung gebracht.
Ja.
Sie haben Ufren, Ibuprofen eingenommen, aber es funktioniert nicht.
Okay.
Keine Unfall, keine Verletzung.
Und keine neurologische Symptome.
Okay.
Ja.
Okay, ich erkläre Ihnen, was ich machen soll.
So erst, ich überprüfe Ihre Atemfrequenz,
Herzfrequenz, Körpertemperatur und Blutdruck.
Dann ich untersuche Ihre Halsbereiche.
Nach meiner Meinung, diese kann diese Beschwerde
von Halsbibelsäulen ersacht werden.
Ah, ja, okay.
Aber ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Du erst, wir machen notwendige Untersuchungen
und dann notwendige Labor-Untersuchungen.
Und ich nehme Blut ab und eine Röntgenaufnahme
machen Ihre Halsbereiche.
Sie machen eine Röntgenaufnahme vom Hals, okay?
Ja, vom Hals.
Ich habe auch viele Probleme,
die von Gehin verursacht werden.
Aber ich glaube, das ist nicht von Gehin verursacht werden.
Aber wir müssen anstehend denken.
Und wir werden machen,
vielleicht nachdem Untersuchung,
ich werde mich entscheiden,
aber wir werden vielleicht Kranialpomografie machen.
Pomografie ist ein bildgebendes Verfahren
für Körperlöse.
Wir haben ein Bild von Gehin und Tassis,
aber es gibt auch noch andere.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das machen will.
Lassen Sie uns erst mal gucken, ob es vielleicht auch anders geht.
Ja, okay.
Ich habe einen Kollegen, der auch fragt.
Sind Sie aufgefahren?
Nein, das ist nämlich nicht aufgefallen.
Welche Hand benutzt ihr auf der Arbeit?
Ich arbeite am Computer, da brauche ich beide Hände,
aber ich bin eigentlich Rechtshänder.
Also die Maus bedienen ich rechts, ja.
Wie ist das für Sie?
Es geht so.
Ich spiele manchmal Volleyball,
aber vielleicht zwei Mal im Monat.
Im Sommer gehe ich auch gerne schwimmen.
Ich fahre auch viel Fahrrad,
aber dass ich jetzt so richtig ein großer Sportler bin,
kann ich nicht sagen.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich den Kopf gar nicht bewegen kann.
Dass ich den ganzen Körper mitnehmen muss,
wenn ich zur Seite gucken will,
weil das alles zu sehr weh tut.
Wenn Sie Kopfbewegung haben,
dann welche Hand,
die ich in der Hand habe,
wie ich es mit dem Kopf bewegen kann.
Dann lassen Sie mich überlegen.
Dann schießt es wirklich so.
Dann wird es vielleicht,
dann habe ich gesagt, 6,
dann ist es vielleicht 7 oder 8.
Aber es ist jedenfalls so,
dass ich das Gefühl habe,
ich kann das Gefühl haben,
dass es alles fest ist
und ich kann den Kopf gar nicht bewegen.
Sie haben am Anfang gesagt,
linken Seite, Kopfschmelzen.
Im Hals linken Seite auch schmelzen.
Ja, linker Hals und Hinterkopf
und linke Schulter.
Danke schön.
Sie haben gesagt,
Ibuprofen eingenommen,
welche Dosierung und wie viel mal eingenommen.
Oh, ich weiß gar nicht,
was steht denn da drauf auf der Packung, Ibuprofen?
Ich hatte da noch so eine Schachtel liegen,
ich weiß gar nicht, wie viel da drin ist.
Kann das sein, 600?
Zwei Mal habe ich das probiert,
jeweils eine zu nehmen,
aber ich hatte nicht den Eindruck, dass das hilft.
Danke schön.
Sie haben gesagt, am Anfang kein Unfall.
Ich habe keinen Unfall gehabt.
Ich würde gerne wissen,
dass Sie in den letzten Tagen etwas Schweres aufgehoben haben.
Nein, ich habe nichts Schweres gehoben.
Nein, ist mir nicht.
Nein, also nur normale Gewichte.
Ich habe vielleicht meine Sprudelkiste angehoben,
aber das mache ich häufig.
Sie haben gesagt, Tinnitus.
Ja, ich habe Probleme mit Tinnitus, das stimmt.
Einige Seite oder beide Seite?
Auf einer Seite, aber auf der rechten Seite.
Rechten Seite, nicht die rechten Seite.
Ich habe das nicht.
Aber auf der rechten Seite.
Auf der rechten Seite, nicht die rechten Seite.
Dagegen, haben Sie,
sind Sie in irgendeiner Art?
Ich war damals mal beim Arzt,
aber der hat gesagt, das ist nicht so ausgeprägt
und im Augenblick machen wir nichts dagegen.
Danke schön.
Einstündigung, leiden Sie unter
unter Morgensteifigkeit im heißen Bereich?
So an normalen Tagen? Nein.
Jetzt ja, aber also das ist ein ganz, ja nicht Morgensteifigkeit,
es ist immer das Problem, dass ich das nicht, also jetzt diese Tage.
Aber sonst normalerweise habe ich morgens nicht mehr Beschwerden als sonst.
Ist Ihnen übel oder mussten Sie sich übergeben?
Ja, hat ja gefragt und ich habe bestätigt, dass mir schlecht ist,
aber übergeben musste ich mich nicht.
Okay, vielen Dank.
In der letzten Zeit, zwei bis drei Wochen,
haben Sie Erkältung?
Ich war nicht erkältet, nein.
Können wir Arsatzgesprache anfangen?
Ja, ich glaube ja. Ich glaube auch.
Ja, ich versuche.
Guten Tag Frau Oberarzt, ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten,
darf ich Ihnen vorstellen?
Ja, aber natürlich, wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Okay, ich habe einen neuen Patienten, er heißt Andreas Schultern.
Er ist 33 Jahre alt und 1,86 m groß und 98 kg schwer.
Herr Schultern hat sich wegen seit vier Tagen heftiger Schmerzen im Kopf vorgestellt.
Die Schmerzen strahlen in linken Arm und hinter dem Kopf.
Laut der Patienten liegt der Schmerzintensität bei acht auf der Schmerzkala.
Er hat gegen diese Schmerzen Ibuprofen eingenommen,
aber es hat nicht funktioniert.
Nur Wärme-Kissen, ein bisschen verbessert die Schmerzen.
Das hat ein bisschen Linder rumgebracht.
Ja, ein bisschen.
Und als Begleitensymptoma berichtete er nichts.
Nur er fühlt sich nicht gut, ein bisschen müde und schlapp.
Und ihr Appetit ist ein bisschen in Appetit, in Appetenz.
In Appetenz? Okay, was besteht denn noch?
Und in der linken Hand hat er Sitten.
Ah, ja, okay.
Aber keine neurologische Probleme sonst.
Als vor Erkrankungen er gab,
hat er sich seit fünf Jahren Tinnitus.
Und mit acht Lebensjahren würde er operiert wegen...
Im achten Lebensjahr?
Im achten Lebensjahr oder mit acht Jahren?
Ja, mit acht Jahren würde er operiert wegen Unterbruchen.
wegen einer Unterarmfraktur?
Ja, Unterarmfraktur.
Er nimmt keine Medikamente.
Und er hat Polen-Allergie.
Und die Allergie äußert sich als Peuschelupfen.
Und er raubt fünftigerete täglich und seit zwölf Jahren.
Und zwei, drei Bier pro Woche.
Er hat keine Drogen.
Er raubt 50er Recken am Tag und trinkt zwei bis drei Bier oder zwei Bier in der Woche.
Okay, er nimmt keine Drogen.
Ja, er nimmt keine Drogen.
Als Familienannahmene sehr gab,
hat er sich, Pate und Mutter,
ist seit kein Problem.
Pate ist 70 Jahre alt und vor zwei Jahren hat er,
oder hat sie eine Stand-Operation bekommen.
Hat er eine Stand-Operation bekommen, ein Corona-Stand?
Ja, Corona-Stand bekommen.
Mutter hat vor vier Jahren eine Kniegelenk,
künstliches Kniegelenk bekommen.
Die sagen wir dazu?
Ja, was?
Was sagen wir dazu in der Haarsprache?
Ja, totalen Dokretäts.
So sehr anonym, er gab sich,
er ist ein Beamter in Einwohneramt
und besondere Belastung,
Arbeitsstress hat er, er ist ledig, aber mit ihrer Freundin.
Seiner Freundin?
Seine Freundin lebt.
Lebt er zusammen?
Ja, er lebt zusammen.
Ja, das war es.
Was ist der Diagnose der Verdachtsdiagnose?
Ja, meine Verdachtsdiagnose ist,
als wir bei Soil sind.
Was könnte es differentialdiagnostisch noch sein?
Ja, als differentialdiagnostisch überlege ich,
gehin sehrebrovascular Erreignisse kann sein,
subarachnovidal Blutung,
epidemiologische oder epidural oder interdurale Hämologie kann sein.
Oder, dass es stressbedingte Kopfschmerzen auch sein,
oder wir können Migräne,
für die Aufklärung,
Solumbiam machen,
Bildgebende verpausen,
zum Beispiel Daniel MRT oder...
Was würde man als erstes vielleicht machen?
Erstens,
welche Bildgebung würde man sofort mit einem MRT anfangen?
Nein, erst werden wir Röntgenaufnahme.
Wir machen erst mal Röntgen in zwei Ebenen.
Zwei Ebenen sollen wir Computertomografie machen,
vielleicht, oder Sie meinen Bildgebenden?
Ich würde erst mal Radeo,
HWS-Aufnahme in zwei Ebenen, oder nicht?
Oder macht man dann nur eine Ebenen?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich glaube, für meine Verdachtdiagnose zuerst,
Halspilbel solle, deswegen,
wir sollen Röntgenaufnahme machen,
Knochen beurteilen.
Was würden Sie denn jetzt bei der körperlichen Untersuchung
als erstes machen?
Ja, Körpeli untersuchen,
ich untersuche die Uskalator im Halsbereich.
Auf Altell?
Ja, und dann die allgemeine Körpeli-Untersuchung,
wie ich schon erzählt,
aber im Halspilbel solle,
ich glaube, wir können nicht seit bestimmter Befund haben.
Warum?
Viele Befunde gibt es.
Da kommt jetzt ein Hinweis rein,
dass man natürlich...
...hörte logische Untersuchung,
wenn jemand solche Kopfschmerzen hat,
dass man eben neurologisch ein paar Tests macht.
Er sagt ja, er hat keine Ausfälle,
aber das müsste man sicherlich...
müsste man sicherlich testen,
wenn man sich in der Linke hat, z.B. oder...
...perfere Motorische PMSD,
Untersuchung muslimischer durchführen.
Ja, ich meine, die Untersuchung von muskulaturer Systemen
können wir nicht viel befunden haben.
Deswegen, natürlich, wir müssen deutsche Situationen
neurologische Untersuchung durchführen.
Neurologische Untersuchung, ja, genau.
Ja, und es kann auch Gehintmörs sein,
oder ein...
Das könnte es auch sein, ja.
...nur Plasen in der Kopf sein.
Und deswegen, wir müssen neurologische Untersuchung machen.
Ja, aber wir müssen ja denken,
dass der Patient 33 Jahre alt und...
Ja, sehr jung, ja.
Ja, das ist nicht erst mal, aber erst mal...
...auch erst mal ihr habt gedacht,
dass es für die Menschen so leise sein wird.
Ja, das ist auch sehr...
...der...
...sweite mal, dass z.B. ein Stressbedingter Kopf schmärtsen,
oder Kurusste schmärtsen, es gibt viele Pärscher,
der Kopf schmärtsen.
Genau.
Und dann vielleicht ein Hemorrhagie oder andere Sachen können wir denken,
aber das ist...
Schritt für Schritt, ne?
Wir machen Ausschussdiagnose, denn wenn dich eins bestätigt, ne?
Ich bin kardiologe, deswegen...
...ich kann diese denken.
Erst mal Migren, zweit mal Neokartik-Farcus.
Neokartik-Farcus.
Achso!
Neokartik-Farcus, weil die Patienten eine,
zwei...
...ein Risikofaktor, drei Risikofaktor, einmal Männisch,
zweimal Familienamnese,
zweimal Zigarette, Raucher.
Aber minimal Raucher, ja.
Ja, und keine Sport, nur jeden Tag im Büro arbeitet.
Drei Risikare alt und deswegen möchte ich erst mal
differenzial die Akkorde-Sendung denken.
Aha, okay.
Ich würde sagen...
...und der Patient hat gesagt, keine Zerstörung,
keine O-Störung, keine...
Nein, doch, O-Störung, Tinnitus.
Nicht O-Zoise Anders, Tinnitus Anders.
O Zerstörung haben wir gesehen.
Als HNO, als würde ich sagen,
eine junge Patientin haben wir,
und der hat Tinnitus seit fünf Jahren
und er hat gelegentlich Kopfschmerzen.
Aber seit vier Tagen eine schwere oder heftige Kopfschmerzen.
Deswegen, ich würde machen in der Türkei zum Beispiel.
Ich bin HNO erst in der Türkei.
Zuerst HNO-Untersuchung.
Und wenn es alles gut geklappt ist,
wenn alles in Ordnung ist,
dann würde ich machen ein Ermarschaufnahme.
Ja, ja, ja.
Aber das ist interessant.
Wenn Sie Ihre Diskussion angucken,
dann sehen Sie, dass wir zwei Pfarrerzter haben
und verschiedene Ansatz haben.
Dr. Gündiz guckt von der kalbiologischen Seite drauf
und Sie gucken von der HNO-Seite drauf.
Das ist ja eigentlich spannend.
Ich meine, das ist ja auch logisch,
dass jeder aus seinem Fachgebiet und aus seinen Erfahrungen spricht.
Unser Mensch, da würde ich aber nachgucken.
Und da würde ich nachgucken.
Gut, ich denke mal, wir sind ja mit diesen Patienten
jetzt relativ weit.
Tatsächlich ist es ja ein HWS-Syndrom.
Gott sei Dank hat dieser junge Mann keine Sib-Aufregelung.
Er hat keinen Hirntumor.
Er hat auch keinen Infarkt,
sondern er hat einfach durch schlechte Körperhaltung
wenig Ausgleichssport.
Er hat ein HWS-Syndrom.
Und dann muss man das entsprechend behandeln.
Was wären denn die Therapieoptionen,
wenn man tatsächlich landet beim HWS-Syndrom?
Ja, Therapie, es kommt darauf an.
Und zuerst, wir machen Analgesie.
Und dann, Physiotherapie, nach meiner Meinung nach funktioniert gut.
Und regelmäßig Kontrolle oder eine z.B. Orthopädie-Konsul können wir schreiben.
Ja, genau.
Also, dass der möglicherweise bessere Körperhaltung
oder der Muskel aufbaut oder so, dass er Physiotherapie bekommt,
dass er Krankenimmunastik bekommt.
Kann man sagen, Lebensverhaltung an der Umgangung?
Ja, Lebensfung an der Umgangung.
Welche Schulung, das heißt, eine Schulung empfehlen,
der hat gesagt,
eine Körperhaltung, oder?
Haltung, ja.
Körperhaltung, ja.
Ja, ich denke, so etwas würde man als Optimierung
auf das Arbeitsplatz, ist sowas wäre auch wichtig.
Man sagt, hat der einen Arbeitsplatz,
wo er gute Lichtverhältnisse hat,
wo er eine gute Sitzposition hat,
kann er zwischendurch vielleicht mal stehen.
Heutzutage ja auch durchaus im Trend,
dass man zwischendurch sich hinstellen kann bei der Arbeit,
dass man nicht den ganzen Tag sitzen muss.
Solche Sachen könnte man natürlich machen.
Ja, und ausgleichende Gymnastik, regelmäßig Sport,
klar, Lebensführung ändern, insofern richtig.
Gut, ja, halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden über Herrn Scholten,
was bei Ihren Untersuchungen rausgekommen ist,
das sage ich jetzt als Oberärztin,
und als Ihre Gesprächspartnerin für die Übung,
kann ich sagen, ich finde, Sie haben eine sehr schöne Anamnese gemacht,
präzise, und Sie sind eigentlich auch gleich auf die Sachen eingegangen,
die der Patient geschildert hat, und haben das immer wieder aufgenommen,
haben entsprechend nachgefragt.
Eine Augenblick, eine Windigkeit ist mir aufgefallen,
ja, das ist ein gern gemachter Fehler,
wird immer wieder gefragt, haben Sie Erfahrungen mit den Drohungen?
Nein, wir nehmen da überhaupt gar keinen Artikel,
wir nehmen weder einen bestimmten, noch einen unbestimmten Artikel,
wir fragen nur, haben Sie Erfahrungen mit Drohungen?
Ja, das ist ungefähr so, als wenn Sie im Supermarkt fragen,
wo finde ich Reis oder wo finde ich Nudeln?
Ja, das ist der allgemeinen Begriff, nehmen wir keinen Artikel dazu.
Dann ist mir aufgefallen, das ist ein kleiner Grammatikfehler,
der mir aber echt weh getan hat,
wie ist denn das Partizip von B Schreiben,
ein unregelmäßiges, nicht beschreibt,
nein, beschrieben, das war aber eine sehr spezielle Geschichte.
Und zum Schluss haben Sie mir noch den Gefallen getan,
und sind in jede Falle getappt, die da bereit liegt,
nämlich bei Ihrem Vorgehen, dass Sie gesagt haben,
dann ich untersuche, zuerst wir machen.
Liebe, liebe Leute, es ist immer dasselbe.
Das Verb kommt an die zweite Stelle.
Dann untersuche ich, zuerst machen wir eine körperliche Untersuchung,
was auch immer.
Es klingt einfach viel richtiger,
und damit können Sie präsentieren,
dass Sie sehr gutes Deutsch sprechen.
Normalerweise, wenn ich schreibe, achte ich darauf,
aber wenn ich spreche, das kann ein bisschen schwierig sein.
Aber ich würde schon sagen,
dass Sie eigentlich sehr, sehr firm sind in der deutschen Sprache,
und dass das, was eben nicht hundertprozentig richtig ist,
schon so auch unter diese Kategorie fällt,
so charmante Abweichung.
Also ich denke mal, da steht jedem zu, der kein Muttersprachler ist,
nur weil ich das ungefähr jeden Abend, wo wir zusammen sind,
sage ich das.
Deswegen fand ich das jetzt witzig, dass es auch wieder kam.